I'm Todd Park I'm the chief technology
officer of HHS the first thing you
should know about me is that my job
title is a giant red herring I do not
run technology at HHS I was actually
recruited for a position that they
recently created about 20 months ago to
be an entrepreneur in residence and that
actually was the phrase that really got
me interested because when they first
called me you know I was wondering why
they called me because I'd never working
out before I know nothing about
government but they said actually we are
calling you on purpose because you're an
entrepreneur and we want to create an
entrepreneur esence position and your
job is to be 100% focused on being a
change agent to create and lead major
new projects HHS that help HHS harness
the power of data technology innovation
to propel at which point we moved from
here which is an incredibly lovely place
so wonderful be here today and I'm doing
my true duty in DC and I'll tell you and
this may be shocking to you but it is
not hyperbole is that the last 20 months
have been the most entrepreneurial
experience of my life by significant
margin and at the root of it HHS is
thinking very entrepreneurially about
how to spur entrepreneurship and that's
what I like to talk about today so I
would submit to you that right here
right now there's never been a better
moment to be a healthcare innovator in
American history why is this it's
because to megatrends which i've been
waiting for personally since I was a
small child are finally walking in an
epic epic form and scale the first is
massive incentive change which has begun
which we'll talk about and the second is
information leave at ASEAN which is also
locking in in multiple exciting respects
collectively new incentives and
information Libre CEO an equal rocket
fuel for innovation rocket fuel for
entrepreneurs rocket fuel for change in
American healthcare so let's talk about
each of these trends the first is new
incentives have you heard about
meaningful use
who here has not heard about me please
okay so for those of you that haven't
heard about making very long story short
is part of the Recovery Act there's a
sub act called the high tech act
essentially it authorizes Medicare and
Medicaid to pay bonuses of 44 to 63
thousand dollars per dock or two million
dollars per hospital for the adoption
and meaningful use of electronic health
records this is very very
citing for multiple reasons it's a giant
impetus for the adoption and use of
electronic health records very saying as
well because it doesn't actually pay you
just for buying the technology and
showing Medicare the receipt you
actually have to use it in ways that
improve care and the standard for what
that means improving care excuse me has
been defined through a very open public
process initially it's capturing the
right data about patients and sharing it
it's moving to then clinical process
improvement and then finally to improve
outcomes and this is fantastic but it's
just an appetizer is absolutely not the
main event the main event which is
actually not broadly known shockingly
even in health care but it's becoming
more broadly known hopefully is the
Affordable Care Act and what it's doing
to change how providers will be paid in
America I would submit to you that if
you really want the health system to
change if you want to actually optimize
quality efficiency in health you have to
change how we pay for health care does
everyone in the room know how we pay for
health care today with those of you
don't the way we pay for health care the
way we've always paid for health cares
by the yard right by the piece we pay
per physician visit we pay per hospital
stay we pay per surgeon so what do you
get the rule the markets you get what
you pay for
we get rapidly escalating volumes of
doctor visits surgeries and hospital
stays so far from our system being
dysfunctional I would argue it's
functioning perfectly its delivering
exactly what society wants it to do as
signaled by payment so the problem is is
that these rapidly escalating volumes of
services or famously not correlated with
rapidly escalating quality of care
health and outcomes and that is the
pickle that we're in today so the thing
the Affordable Care Act does which I
believe is the single most important
feature of the whole law is it actually
authorizes directs and funds Medicare
the biggest payer in the country to
shift how it pays from pay for volume to
pay for value to pay for health to pay
for quality unless this happens
innovations that improve quality
efficiency are never going to take hold
because if you actually introduced an
innovation in today's healthcare system
that improves quality that helps people
stay healthy
prevents them being readmitted to the
hospital prevents them from in the ER
that's actually a negative business case
for the healthcare system it can't
really adopt that because it loses money
by doing so so it's a wish somehow that
helices won't actually try to become
more efficient and higher quality right
to wish that it actually will become
higher quality more efficient in such a
fee-for-service reimbursement system is
crack-smoking that's never gonna happen
but if you actually morph how you pay
from pay for law and pay for health and
value
I predict I think we're all beginning to
see this that you'll see some remarkable
momentum toward efficiency quality we'll
talk more about that in a second and
there are a whole series of provisions
the Affordable Care Act that actually
underpin this this megatrend so there
are accountable care organizations
patient-centered medical homes but the
case rates etc but the fundamental punch
line is that they incent quality the
incentive fish'n see they even sent
health they incent working hard to keep
people out of the ER out of the hospital
and fund the work required to do that
and the most important vision of all is
something called the Center for Medicare
and Medicaid innovation the CMMI Sachin
Jain is that you so I have to come to
California to meet you Sachin is a key
player in the CMMI the new Innovation
Center which is actually I think the
best kept secret American healthcare but
rapidly becoming more broadly known an
incredibly important organization
understand the CMMI is a new center set
up within Medicare which has been given
ten billion dollars to identify validate
and scale new ways of paying for care
their NPV positive for Medicare they
actually improved quality and lower cost
the most important thing to understand
about in my opinion is not the ten
billion dollars it's it's actually a
special power it's been given by the
Affordable Care Act that Medicare has
never been given which is the following
if it identifies a new way paying for
care that the CMS actuary validates as
lowering costs and improving quality and
CMAs actuary for those of you don't know
is famously a political and lobby able
right does not give a crap about
anything but the numbers and the results
it seems actuary says this is cool then
the Secretary of HHS has
the ability to turn that into national
medicare payment policy through the
rulemaking process is the most
scientific evidence-based process for
changing our Medicare pays the Medicare
has ever been given and I would submit
to you that the reason why Medicare has
not changed how how it pays is not
because of people Medicare don't want to
do it they've known since you were small
children need to do it it's Congress has
never given them the authority to
actually pursue a rationale we designed
payment but now Congress has given them
that process and that is a big big big
deal but I can tell you on behalf of HHS
that we think this is the ballgame that
we are going to be using this authority
the Innovation Center the funding to
really drive how Medicare changes
payment and why is that a really really
big deal it's not just because Medicare
is a big payer it's because the private
insurers tend to copy what Medicare does
in this case they're saying hallelujah
it's about time because we've been
trying to do this forever but we can't
because Medicare continues to pay
fee-for-service and doctors can't
function half in a world that's thief or
service and half in the world where
they're trying to proactively optimize
health and practically coordinate care
and do a whole bunch of stuff that a few
service system actually doesn't pay for
so by Medicare finally moving this
direction actually unlocks the desire of
all the other payers to do the same
thing and so you'll see in the next two
years a huge change in payment this is
actually in my opinion one of the most
powerful disruptive changes in history
American health care and it's gonna be a
big big big deal so why is this Mother's
Milk for innovation well if you actually
think about the new kinds of care
delivery systems that have to arise as
you think about how an industry has to
more from a mindset where it's
essentially optimizing throughput and
seeing as many people as possible to one
where it's actually proactively
monitoring the health of its population
and patients understanding what care
people have gotten identifying gaps in
care filling those gaps coordinating
with other provision of other providers
keeping people out of the year the
hospital I mean that's a very very big
shift to go from fee-for-service
essentially table turn throughput
maximizing operations to proactive
population health maximizing operations
the great news here for innovators and
entrepreneurs is that that's a huge
opportunity that's a huge opportunity
because actually to do
the kinds of things I just said requires
a whole bunch of muscles that doctors
and hospitals don't have today the
ability to actually aggregate data mine
it identify gaps in care the ability
actually do decision support so you do
the stitch in time that saves the ER
visit the ability actually coordinating
integrate care across lots of different
providers the ability to extend the
reach of the physician outside the walls
of the physician's office into the home
and other other settings the ability
engaged consumers to get them engaged in
their care help them stay compliant with
their meds potentially using some of the
tools and insights from the previous two
presentations this is actually very
exciting because actually these muscles
while they might seem like a stretch to
doctrine hospitals our muscles have been
built in other sectors and perfected and
there's a massive opportunity to
actually transpose these muscles
translated for healthcare into the
healthcare space it's an opportunity in
a nutshell to re instrument a two point
five trillion dollar industry to
actually not optimize for volume but
optimize for health I think it's the
greatest entrepreneur to since the
internet and one that will actually
change the course of American healthcare
and create huge economic value at the
same time so that's that's trend number
one is incentive change really really
big deal the second megatrends
information Liberace on there are three
parts to information Liberace on the
first is a rising tide of patient data
liquidity so what this means in a
nutshell is that the information that
was in manila folders and doctors
offices as we presume mission blessing
is going electronic but it's not useful
really unless those electrons can move
right if all we do is move from paper
chart rooms to e look chart or
electronic chart rooms where the
electrons cannot move around that's not
incredibly helpful so there's a bunch of
work that's actually happening to ensure
that the electrons can in fact move
around so here's the direct project and
you might hear heard of the direct
project the drug project is actually a
great illustration of government to know
how HHS is rolling in the contemporary
era so this is actually branching story
so there's a hearing a public hearing
where a doctor testified in front of the
committee and said look I've got this
problem I haven't either chronic health
record I have a patient I want to send
to another doctor who has an electronic
health record
both have the same in the trot comforter
from the same company how do I get this
patient record from me to the doctor the
other doctor and he said actually
literally the only way I could figure
out how to do this was to print it out
and fax it so she would type it into her
EHR he said but of course this is insane
so he actually ended up emailing it and
which point the committee had a heart
attack because he broke three laws in
the process he said look I understood
that was bad but look I know you guys
are thinking all these fancy thoughts
can you just help me with this
fundamental problem how do I get the
record from me to her and so he said
well we can help you with that problem
but instead of actually appointing a
Blue Ribbon Commission of government
eggheads to think really hard about in a
conference room we actually did the
opposite we challenged the country to
come up with the answer so we announced
that we were convening a collaborative
called the direct project collaborative
we created a wiki space and series of
public means where anyone could come
together and anybody could come together
and join the collaborative solve the
problem over 60 private sector companies
came together to solve the problem
including people who are blood enemies
of each other but because the government
is providing a neutral honest broker
convening ground they actually agreed to
work together within less than 90 days
they came with a spec for secure
healthcare email simple brilliant a few
months later they had it in production
and now over 70 companies I believe
representing over 90% of the electronic
healthcare marketplace have committed to
implement direct email this year this is
all basically within within within a
year this happened with actually
microscopic government investment just
convening for the industry to come up
with an answer super quickly and one
that actually is producing very
practical results a second product I
just want to talk about is called blue
button have you heard of blue button a
blue button is another vegetable product
that we actually launched relatively
recently and turns out that the Veterans
Administration Medicare and the
department defense are three of the
largest repositories of personal health
information in the world Medicare has
records of claims payment for 47 million
seniors and the VA and DOD deliver
health care directly to several million
people veterans and members of the
military so blue button is the
capability where essentially we gave
each Medicare beneficiary veteran and
with military the ability to download
the copy electronically of their own
data so you can go to a website
authenticate yourself and hit a blue
button that looks like right there and
download the copy of your information
this took us about 17 lines of code it
was very easy to do but it's actually
become a really big deal because in the
private sector this is not necessarily
common they really actually download a
copy of your own information and then
move it wherever you want is not common
in fact we had after we deployed this in
beta in October we had private sector
folks call us and say was that legal for
you to do is it a HIPAA violation to
actually give a patient a copy of their
own information you were trialing we
said dude we're the US government if we
were illegal we probably wouldn't have
done it but illustrates the level of
confusion about this and so more and
more private firms are actually now
doing this and we've actually not
marketed this at all but since October
of last year actually now 300,000 unique
users have downloaded a copy of their
own data and are uploading its personal
health records and other applications
are being built to actually suck up this
day to make it useful so rising tide of
healthy liquidity cuz that's very
important to feed the instruments that
will help doctors and hospitals
understand what the hell's going on
coordinate care and do the stitch in
time that will save the ER visit or the
hospital mission a second component of
information liebe nación is market
transparency what defines a market how
to submit to you that actually a market
is characterized by knowing price and
performance the ability actually make a
choice based on price performance if
that's the definition of a market this
health care market not so much so one of
the other things the Affordable Care Act
does the health firm law that's very
important that's actually also not
really bet that broadly know is it
brings massive new transparency to the
market there's a site called
healthcare.gov we launched last year I
was in Paris on vacation and I got a
call from my boss and he said Todd the
White House just called they want you to
lead the building the site called
healthcare.gov it's supposed to have
every single private and public
insurance plant in America on it and it
has to be built in 60 days I said Bill
what he said but feel free to work on
after you come back from vacation
I said bill I should start working out
six months ago but long story short we
pulled together a team of folks and we
pulled the site together and it's the
first site that actually compiles every
private and public insurance plan in
America benefit information October we
added pricing information so you can
compare them against each other there
have been other sites like a health
insurance com that have a subset of the
data but those are voluntary sites
because only HHS only the government can
actually say if you're an insurer you're
required by law to actually disclose
your products pricing the benefits and
so that's why we were able to create
this comprehensive inventory on the
provider side the government's actually
been compiling for some time now
hospital nursing home quality data we're
actually now going to be compiling
physician quality data all through a
very open public process talking with
Doc's consumers expected etcetera and
publishing that data as well as well as
deepening our Hospital Compare and other
other modality quality data so again
bring more transparency into the
healthcare provider marketplace and the
final component of information we
brought see I want to talk about is the
health data initiative have you heard
about the Health Day initiative this is
amazing accidentally because this is a
group of health care folks folks who
actually very sophisticated very very
smart who are building companies running
companies running actually major provide
institutions and a lot of what I've been
talking about is actually not stuff you
heard about and this is why I've been
telling people in DC I said look all the
policy in the world isn't gonna help
anybody if nobody knows it's there if
the policies were trying to actually
implement to help spur innovation are
not known by the innovators that's not
very helpful so it's great it's great to
have a chance to connect with you today
and actually I'd love to brainstorm
further about opportunity to carry the
message further so the health English is
actually a really big deal
and making a long story short the gist
of it is are you familiar with NOAA the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric in this
region so NOAA collects it turns out
virtually all weather data in the United
States and it turns out that does
something very interesting with this
data which is it chooses to publish all
of it online in machine readable format
download by anybody for free well that
influx probably constrain that then
feeds a whole bunch of privates of
innovation
Weather Channel weather comm with a spot
komm I was just talking to no Khosla who
started a crop insurance company which
is growing like crazy
whether bill based on NOAA data many
news cast etc none in which the
government has to pay for then which the
government choreographed and which
creates huge value for the American
people so he said that's awesome
and the government's actually run this
play previously with GPS data right by
releasing that which since spawned tons
of innovation financial data which
spawned tons of innovation so he said
let's run that play for health data and
as the experiment last March we pulled
together a small meeting about 45
innovators a mix of healthcare rockstars
and tech rockstars like Don Berwick and
Tim O'Reilly and we said look we've got
this idea for HHS to become the NOAA of
health data because we've got tons of
data is this is a colossal stupid idea
or does it have legs they got very
excited about it we said okay let's
start with a limited set of data
community health data the national state
regional local data on smoking obesity
access healthy food and hospital and
nursing home quality data right if we
release that data and formulas really
easy to find really easy to use and work
with its developer what would you do
with it they brainstormed about 20
classes of applications that they would
build that could use that data to help
consumers doctors employers mayor's make
their decisions and improve health we
said ok well in less than 90 days June
2nd Secretary Sebelius will host a giant
public Lollapalooza any of you who can
build one of the apps you brainstormed
will showcase you and make you famous we
weren't exactly sure what would happen
next but what happened next was these
innovators rose to the occasion and
they're friends of the Front's friends
and on June 2nd less than 90 days after
that initial meeting after a week after
the initial mean we actually put the day
since we talked about and very easy to
find very easy used form on the website
less than nine days later they debuted
20 plus brand new or upgraded
applications leveraging our data that
were amazing so I'll just talk about a
couple of real quick so one of timber
riley's laws about how data changes
people's lives is if you want data to
help people don't make them find it make
the data find people where they already
are
where they're making decisions where the
day can be helpful so being took this to
heart they actually took our Hospital
Compare data which is awesome data
it's like hospital by hospital quality
of patients at which nobody knows about
and we actually deploy it on a website
that nobody goes to
a hospital barcode they actually
download the data and they integrated in
the search so for a bunch of hospitals
not all but for a bunch of hospitals if
you type in the name of the hospital it
pulls up in the primary search result
the patient satisfaction with that
hospital versus the average I just use
this to determine the hospital
that my wife will deliver so I can show
that and it's incredibly useful and I've
actually I must confess I've never been
to HHS's Hospital for a website I would
know how to use it if you found me so
this is actually really really
interesting company called iTriage which
is a really awesome handheld find
medical treatment I learn about
procedures research diseases find doctor
app integrated our Community Health
Center directory into it options for
free and low-cost care and they've
gotten tons of people using iTriage
since June 2nd last year to find free
low-cost care options again without us
spending a dime people built dashboards
and local tools to help employers and
communities and help ends understand
where the issues were where investments
could be made people built games this
actually and so I was talking about this
this is called community clash comm a
startup called me you health in Boston
wholly owned by Healthways disease
managed company built this in 14 days
it's healthcare blackjack so essentially
what happens is you go to community
clash track time you pick a city like
Boston you pick an opposing city like
New York and you are dealt five cards
facedown
each of which corresponds to a health
indicator like smoking or obesity you're
allowed to substitute up to two cards
out for other indicators where you think
you beat New York then you show your
cards and that may sound silly to you
but actually in the expo after the main
presentations I should Rica's sample
yourself any of the apps that you want
on June 2nd the longest line by far was
for this game it is strangely addictive
in a way I can't explain and the reason
why I think this is important because
it's a lustrum of a trend gamification
which I think has actually profound
implications for health and healthcare
so everyone here knows farmville right
does anyone here know how many users
farmville acquired in its first 18
months 73 million get what from zero to
73 million monthly users in 18 months
I'll submit to you the person who
invents health bill and gets 50 million
plus people playing a game
that they want to play that's fun to
play that's habit-forming that helps
teach them about health by the way the
side effect that person will be one of
the most important public health figures
of the play first century because they
will do more to engage people on their
health then all they eat your spinach
programs in the world combined because a
year span should have been proven to be
a colossal failure when it comes to
behavior change as BJ would tell you so
listen to BJ and try to invent health
fill and then the final example is one
call asthmapolis this is a brilliant
example by a entrepreneur named events
occur in NASA Wisconsin he took a GPS
device attached it to an asthma inhaler
linked it to a web app so every time you
use the inhaler it tells you it records
where and when the attack happened so
you can see that on a personalized map
of AD Vincent's it lets you and your
doctor know that there is a study that's
about to come out on asthmapolis show
that in the target population it cut the
rate of uncontrolled asthma in half and
I actually didn't know that 75% of
asthmatics have asthma in uncontrolled
state so cutting that number in half is
a big deal I also didn't know that
actually difference between uncontrolled
and controlled is $3,000 a year per
person and healthcare costs Prismatic
because of lots of complications that
happen if your asthma is actually not
controlled so that's a very very
interesting interesting
breakthrough and there are these new
provider organizations forming under the
mechanisms that medicare is rolling out
to help incent quality health that are
very interested in adopting as ma Pallas
to try to bend the curve on cost of
quality so the best thing about all of
that they're after up real quickly is
that the government actually didn't do
crap Yeah right all the government did
was take a bunch of data make it really
easy to find and use and promote it to
the right innovators and then they did
the rest in less than 90 days they
turned it into a whole panoply of really
cool apps that people are using and they
were helpful and they can help grow
businesses imagine if the government
issued an RFP for any of those apps and
we can't say how low in ninety days let
alone actually get something like that
to happen so this is a wonderful example
of a public/private sector ecosystem
they can drive a lot of value so the
long story short on HDI on healthy
initiatives that we're all in we're
going crazy we're publishing everything
that moves we've greatly expand the
aperture so it's not just Community
Health try to quality data but it's
actually a whole bunch of
because you think about HHS it's
Medicare Medicaid the FDA the NIH the
CDC etc
tons of billions of dollars of data that
taxpayers already paid for that we're
now liberating we're not actually
fleeing it up if it violates privacy or
trade secret but everything else we're
actually publishing I could talk all day
long about all the datasets but I won't
because at any time but actually to make
it easy if you go to health data.gov
it's a one-stop shop for all our free
data and api's we're adding to it more
and more every day there's a ton on
there my favorite tweet because I
monitored the Twitter stream pretty
rigorously is from an entrepreneur Ohio
his tweet tag was health entrepreneur
instance nationally there and he
actually said looking at healthcare.gov
feel like a kid in a candy store which I
just love because hopefully that's the
feeling all of you will have when you
check it out and there's also a forum so
if you don't like a dataset think it
could be improved or see a dataset that
you would like to put on here that you
know about HHS just let us know we're
monitoring that constantly and would
love to hear from you and beyond just
publishing the data we're engaged in an
extensive marketing campaign to
publicize the fact the data exists so
we're doing a bunch of things like
challenges if you were to help to
challenge org this is run by a partner
of ours helped to tie know where any
government agency company or individual
can issue a public challenge for the
best app that does X like the best step
that engages kids with health data so on
and so forth 21 of these have been
issued to date they're very very
exciting we're also doing codeathon so
y'all know what codon is so it's we're
basically hackers get together over a
weekend build something awesome so we're
actually doing that as well just right
time for you know the idea of time no
time okay well this is a picture of one
such codeathon output which I will not
talk about which is really cool anyway
but real stuff is coming out of these
things and more importantly frankly the
codeathon challenges are recruiting a
whole new class of innovators into
healthcare they haven't gotten involved
for there's only one thing I learned as
an entrepreneur my prior life that's
that's actually a replicable lesson
company the company which is which is
this simple fact if you get the best
people you win if you don't you lose you
may not actually lose immediately but
just a matter of time before you do the
same thing as true ecosystems if health
care
the best entrepreneurs on the planet it
will transform we will invent our way
out of a health care problem and so what
we're doing well the reason why I'm here
today is I don't because I like
listening to myself talk it's because
this is incredible opportunity to talk
to the best innovation of health care
and get you even more excited about
doubling down jumping in taking
advantage of incentive change
information liberation to change the
world
and the final point I'll make is that
the other day H just doesn't want to
actually control or drive this health
data ecosystem right we just want to be
a happy date of sugar daddy and a
cheerleader and the facilitator but the
whole point of this health data
ecosystem and this broader health
innovation ecosystem is for it to be
decentralized grassroots and out of
control
completely out of control in fact the
more out of control the better the
latest exhibit in this is going to be
something we're calling our health data
initiative forum which we're holding on
June 9th I want to call it the health
datapalooza into medicine said we can't
call it that we have to call something
more formal I said you know fine call it
health uniform but it's healthy it
pollutes them and what's happening is we
actually for our second anniversary of
our health data initiative specifically
we said we would like companies to come
exhibit and talk about solutions they've
actually built that leverage in part our
data and mashing up with other data and
other capabilities to help consumers
make better decisions help employers
promote health and wellness andrew's
cost help doctors deliver better care
help health systems transmen
transmogrify into accountable care
organizations help mayors make better
investments etc so we had about 40 spots
that we had we're hoping to get 40 we
ended up getting over 70 applications
they were all incredibly good and even
actually applied our second test which
is not only does it deliver concrete
value we also must have a sustainable
business model they can't be a concept
car that has no prayer of actually ever
reaching anybody helping anyone it's
gotta be something that's a sustainable
scalable business model they can
actually serve people and scale to serve
more people even actually applied that
test we couldn't really narrow it down
so we're actually now doing a series of
American Idol style virtual auditions
where people are pitching a committee on
their innovation we're narrowing it down
to 40 I'm Paula Abdul I love everybody
everyone's phenomenal and fabulous my
colleague Greg dining Simon Callow said
you suck that's terrible but actually
it's hard to say that because frankly
they're awesome
and so we're narrowing it down to 40
who'll be showcased at the healthy
initiative forum of June 9th I can't
actually give away their punchlines but
what they've done is absurd is absurd
and that's why I'm so bullish about
healthcare right now it's not because
I've been sitting in my office in DC
thinking really positive pops myself
instead I've spent a lot of time and
last expense talking to hundreds of
healthcare innovators most of whom
you've never heard of who've already
built stuff at the intersection of these
two trends that is awesome stuff that
collectively is going to transform the
healthcare system a lot of it will not
work but a lot of it will and stuff that
works will scale with the aid of these
two mega trends and we are going to
invent our way out of our healthcare
problem American ingenuity will carry
the day at the end the day HHS is roll
this is my big message we are not here
to transform the healthcare system we're
not here to be the innovator right
you're gonna actually transform the
health system you're gonna be the
innovator our rules are simply be a
catalyst and a supporter do everything
we can to fan the flames of these trends
and to help weaponize American
entrepreneurs and innovators to
transform healthcare at a speed and with
a ferocity that will stun the world and
I'm already seeing it begin and it's the
most inspiring inspiring thing so thank
you so much for hearing me out thanks